please welcome Chris Callahan who will
tell us about blockchain consensus hi
there my name is Chris :
and I'm gonna talk to you about
blockchain consensus which is the latest
in a series of consensus algorithms so
that you guys have been studying in this
class um when I use the term blockchain
it's actually really confusing to go out
and read about what blockchain is
because there's so many people who are
excited about it and writing it about it
and using this term in so many different
ways which mean different things and
blockchain can be everything from I'm
gonna make a million dollars to a very
specific data structure so I'm gonna try
and be as precise as possible in my
terminology in this talk um and I'm
probably gonna fail at times and I
apologize for that but um well we'll
give it a go
um I also want to encourage you to
interrupt me at any time during this and
ask questions because that way I get a
better sense of what you guys already
know I don't because I haven't actually
watched all of the previous lectures I'm
sorry about that
um what some of them though so let's
start off just quickly review what
consensus is you've already learned this
but let's assume you've got a bunch of
computers running by their Barrentine
general dictators and you've got a data
structure what you want replicated
across these computers well the way you
do this is by achieving the consensus
between the computers and you can just
replicate the data across a bunch of
computers great so that's the overly
simplified view of consensus how do you
do it
well if you're designing new system you
need to choose an algorithm which you're
going to use in order to achieve
consensus and like good engineers you
always try and start the simplest
possible thing you can come up with and
you do some google searching and you say
oh uh two-phase commit that's the way to
do it and you implement it you discover
well that works great in my system until
one of my computers crashed and rebooted
and then odd added complexity but it's
okay you can actually deal with fail
restart behavior but then one of your
computers catches fire and goes away and
you're whole system comes to a screaming
halt and you're like what the heck just
happened and that's when you realize you
need something more sophisticated such
as paxos or raft which is able to deal
with fail stop behavior as long as you
don't get too many of your machines
family and so you're happy again and
then you get attacked by an evil hack
maybe one of your Byzantine generals
turns into a devil and that devil um
tries to actively subvert your consensus
between your computers and your like I I
actually need to change my system to
tolerate this sort of sub versus
behavior and so you going yeah you'd say
Oh fine I'm gonna implement a Byzantine
fault-tolerant solution and so that's
the next thing you do when you implement
pbft or some other complicated protocol
which can't really tolerate as many
failures it's slower but you know it can
tolerate this Byzantine behavior so
that's kind of cool and then you realize
wait a second oh man having my own pool
of computers and running them and trying
to achieve consensus my application
actually needs me to be able to add
computers to the system over time and
also add computers that aren't mine I
need to have an open system where anyone
can join at any time anyone can leave at
any time
and I achieve consensus between them and
so you go and you consult the theory and
you say oh that's not possible
it's actually there have been many
results throughout time with people
saying proving that it's not possible to
have an open system and achieve
consensus amongst the computers because
you just don't have enough control over
the computers to actually prove that
you're gonna get consensus in all the
cases and so what were you gonna do and
that was thought to be impossible up
until someone came up with blockchain
consensus and blockchain consensus is
kind of cool because it lets us deal
with getting a consensus amongst all of
these computers at computers are adding
and dropping at random times and if you
don't control all the computers but it
has a problem which is it's not really a
consensus it's kind of weird and I'm
gonna get into more detail about how
we'd had to change the definition of
consensus in order to achieve this
suppose if consensus amongst computers
using the blockchain later in this talk
but as we go down through the stack of
algorithms and we get to fancier and
fancier ones I just want to point out
that every step we go down in this chain
we're getting something that's more
general it's also a little bit slower
perhaps requires more messages or even
more time for other reasons than more
messages it's also more complicated so
your goal in designing a disturbing
system
should be to try and start at top the
stack and use a simpler approach if it's
practical for your application and only
go to more complicated solutions if
that's something you absolutely need in
order to achieve whatever you're trying
to build in your system so let's go on
and start off by defining what is a
blockchain but before I go on I want to
pause here and ask if we have any
questions or if the audio isn't working
or anything like that
I think the audio is now working fine
hopefully somebody will that's not the
case huh and uh yeah so I have a
question actually so on the previous
slide so when we so just just to
contextualize this a little bit for our
class so we didn't actually talk about
two-phase commit at all so uh do you
thinking that you could kind of like
explain that very briefly and talk about
how that's a little bit less general
than a consensus protocol like paksas uh
well two-phase commit is simply the idea
of you go through it's actually similar
to pax us and that it has two phases
except you have a controller process
that is trying to achieve consensus
amongst a bunch of slaves and you just
send out one message saying I want to
get chief a consensus on such and such a
transaction happening say transaction a
happening you send that to all your
nodes and they either respond they
respond with a vote they either say yeah
okay I'm willing to do that or I'm not
and then you only proceed to the second
phase the commitment if the first phase
receives a majority of votes saying yes
and so it's just really a way of just
replicating the data across a bunch of
computers in a way where you can either
roll forward or roll backwards and it
comes from the database world where you
also do this with two phase locking
right but it does require you to have
this controller yes it does require
controller it's not fully distributed
like that right right so the word we we
tend to use for that in my class is
decentralized so practice is a
decentralized algorithm so it's it's
more general in that it's tolerant of
that particular kind of failure but it's
it still doesn't it's still not tolerant
of Byzantine faults
oh definitely not so hack so switch
which so we discussed how Paxos behaves
under under omission faults and we
discussed how it behaves under crash
faults but we didn't talk about
Byzantine faults because pectus doesn't
tolerate those so that's that would be a
whole new level of fault tolerance which
we haven't even discussed and so
what Chris is going to talk about is so
blockchain consensus actually actually
can in principle tolerate Byzantine
faults some of them yeah so or at least
yeah a certain class of them so but but
I think this is a good point that Chris
is raising about how you don't
necessarily need that kind of fault
tolerance and it depends it depends on
on on the assumptions that you're making
about your system and and the the the
threat model I suppose the kinds of
faults that you expect to experience
yeah absolutely like for example it
might be really tempting let's say
you're building your own online game say
fortnight and fortnight is a cool system
because it very quickly replicates state
amongst all of the players and if you
don't have very high-speed state
replication amongst all the players the
game is just no fun to play and so it's
really tempting to say gosh wouldn't be
nice to build this in a fully
distributed manner where we don't need
any servers at all and all the players
can just talk in a peer-to-peer fashion
and have the game run except all of the
solutions that we know of for doing that
sort of state replication they are slow
and they would make the game horrible to
play if we tried to do it on the
blockchain for example because you'd
only be able to fire one bullet every
ten minutes and then your bullet might
not actually fire because it might come
back at you twenty minutes later when so
it's it's not the be-all and end-all
solution so before we can talk about how
to achieve consensus on time watching we
need to define what a blockchain is and
so I'm gonna be very specific in this
talk when I say blockchain I'm talking
about the blockchain data structure and
so what is a blockchain data structure
well let's say you've got some data and
you just want to put it on a blockchain
so what you do is you carve off a piece
of that data and you make a block of
data and so it's just a subset of your
data as a block and you can choose
whatever block size you want in Bitcoin
I think they choose a block size of one
megabyte you may have expanded it's two
megabytes it doesn't matter it's just a
fixed sized chunk of data and like any
good data structure you need some
metadata as well so you put some header
on it and for our first block we'll just
leave the headers empty
then when we create a second block on
the top of that in the header what we do
is we put the hash of the first block of
data and that's what chains the blocks
together and that's why it's called a
block chain is because every time you
add some more data you points to the
previous data not through a pointer but
through a hash of the entire contents of
the previous block and when we use this
hash we actually have to use a special
type of hashing function we can't just
use like sum all the bits and XOR em or
whatever we want we have to use
something that's called a cryptographic
hash and the cryptographic hash that
happens to be used by bitcoin is sha-256
but the important property of this
cryptographic hash is it has to be hard
to fake you can't just go and change
some of your data on your first block
and have the same hash on the second
block pointing back at it because then
it doesn't have the properties that are
interesting to us as we build the
blockchain and then as we add more data
we just add more and more blocks using
this technique so that's what a
blockchain is and why is it that a
useful data structure well the thing
that makes it useful is that if you know
the last block of data or even just the
hash of the last block of data you can
then validate that none of your data
structure has been corrupted and so that
means that if you can successfully find
some way of getting just the last block
of data in this entire data structure
which may be megabytes or gigabytes and
size you can then get the other blocks
for anyone in the world evil players
good players nice people mean people and
you know that your data structure hasn't
been corrupted you have a valid correct
copy of the data structure and this is
the chain of trusts that you get from
these hash values so that's kind of cool
so we can just you know validate the
whole data structure great now the
Bitcoin blockchain is exactly this it's
just a bunch of blocks of data that been
chained through these hash values but a
problem that the Bitcoin data structure
has is it's well big there are a lot of
transactions it goes back to the very
beginning of it
every transaction that someone does gets
an entry in one of these blocks and they
keep on adding more and more blocks and
eventually too much um it like right I
tried looking it up and there are
various estimates of the current size of
the Bitcoin data structure it's
something like I think it was three
hundred gigs last time I found someone
that measured it I'm sure it's bigger
now but it's if you launched your own
Bitcoin client on your laptop you
probably don't have to download 300 gigs
of data before you do your first
transaction because that would be kind
of annoying but you do need to download
the Bitcoin blockchain if you want to
validate all the transactions that lead
up to it you want to prove for example
that someone who sent me money actually
has the money to send you so Chris
there's a question in chat right now
which is how exactly does that
validation process work how would you
validate that the last block and the
chain is is correct well that's the key
to the whole thing which is you do it by
running the consensus algorithm the
blockchain consensus in order to get
that block replicated to your computer
successfully and trust that is correct
um but the short answer is is if you
know a lot of nodes in the Bitcoin
universe that are doing mining if you
ask a bunch of them for the latest hash
and they all agree then you're good on
the latest block and if they disagree
then yes don't trust it so much and
that's part and yeah and so establishing
that trust and knowing that you has
received enough information to actually
trust this correct as part of the leap
of faith that's involved in Bitcoin I
would say and so we'll get into faith
issues later because there's partly this
is partially a technical talk and partly
a religion discussion so okay so we have
too much data and so the question is can
we make it so that it's smaller so we
don't the download as much data or true
to our computer in order to do our first
Bitcoin transaction the answer is yes we
use this technology which I haven't told
you've discussed before which is Merkle
trees if in our blocks in the blockchain
we do not store all of the transaction
data but instead in each block we make
it really small and just store a merkel
hash in then our blocks are kind of tiny
and so we can
the whole blockchain without
overwhelming your average laptop or
desktop computer and so what the Merkel
tree is a quick review is you take all
the transaction data and you divide it
up into transactions at the leaves of a
tree and then for every two transactions
you compute the hash of those
transactions and that's a sub tree hash
then you compute the hash of the sub
tree hashes and that's the next level
sub tree hash and so on up until you get
the Merkel hash at the top of the tree
and so why does this help with the
amount of data we have to download well
it turns out if you don't want to
download all the transactions that
involve people's wallets who you are not
transacting with you just don't don't
download that data at all and instead
you just download the data for the
transaction through caribou and then you
can validate it they are correct by
recomputing the subtree hashes above
those and then recomputing the subtree
hashes above that and then recomputing
subtree hash and now we've got the hash
on a block that is on our blockchain and
so we can do the chain validation that
we talked about a second ago just
marching up the blockchain until we get
to the one head node that for who knows
what reason we trust and so we've now
validated that the whole thing is valid
assuming we got the right head
that makes sense and so this is really
not necessary to understand the correct
operation of the blockchain but it's a
really cool performance hack this Markel
tree because allows us to save a lot of
space in terms of what data we need to
download it to do a particular set of
transactions so that is the blockchain
so it turns out that understanding the
blockchain is really simple and all this
stuff which you read online about the
complexity of the blockchain stuff it's
bogus because they're talking about the
blockchain in terms of the entire
ecosystem and not just the simplicity of
the data structure the data structure
itself there's not that much complexity
to it the data structure itself reminds
me of git actually yes yeah no it's it's
it's pretty similar it's well kid is
just reverse stiffing it's just a log
and blockchain transaction log is just
another form of log as well mm-hm
and similarly they use hashes in order
to identify objects in it mm-hmm so ya
know it's it's very similar stalker book
so I've mentioned this already if you're
trying to choose a consensus algorithm
you should just use paxos where after
pbft because they are better algorithms
they're faster and we're gonna harp on
this a lot and it turns out that when
you look at the world of block chains
people use blockchain it's this magical
way of getting venture capital funding
but you can divide it really into two
worlds and one world is the world of
private blockchains these are the people
talking about I'm gonna use a blockchain
to validate that the corn you got on
your table comes from the farm field
which you think it is and they are
usually talking about a private
blockchain where you've got multiple
parties participating but they're all
cooperating parties who you sort of
trust to only set up a fixed set of
servers and not necessarily have random
Joe Q public joined into the blockchain
and add nodes to your to your blocking
um and these private blockchains
the thing they care about is that your
block team was replicated between
participants if any of those
participants tries to suddenly turn evil
the other participants say oh no no I
validate my blockchain and you tried to
change a transaction in the past and
that's bad and so they're just relying
on the properties of the blockchain data
structure but they don't care at all
about a public consensus where nodes can
enter and leave the system at any time
and so those people are much better
served by using a blockchain data
structure but using a traditional
consensus algorithm such as pbft for
replicating their data between machines
and they're going to do that because
there's no way they are gonna spend all
of the electricity and time on this
public consensus out there because it's
a waste it's a waste of effort for them
I do want to point out one thing here
which is this thing about any machine
joining or leaving at any time is very
interesting because so for think of
Paxos for instance so in order for paxos
to work you have to know ahead of time
what a majority is right and so if there
are machines joining and leaving then
that that answered the answer to that
question can change right so
this is this is this idea of dynamic
membership is is actually something that
that Paxos doesn't work very well with
it all meaning doesn't work at all with
I mean there are there are flavors of
paxos right like people have tried to
invent so actually my my colleague here
at UCSC Faisal Nawab has something
called called the deep axis which which
is supposed to work under dynamic
membership I believe but but but I think
it ends up looking a lot more like well
I I hesitate to put words in his mouth
because I don't know how it works but
but but I think it ends up looking
looking more like what what the
consensus protocol that Bitcoin uses
looks like so it's it this is this is
one of those one of those advantages
that you gain by using this more complex
consensus protocol you get you get the
ability to have this dynamic membership
in the in the number of nodes that
you're trying to achieve consensus among
yeah this this is actually something
that it that is key here which is most
consensus protocols other than this one
have somewhere in them buried the
concept of majority and you can only
take an action once you achieve majority
but that involves you have to know what
a majority is and and this public
Bitcoin public consensus doesn't have a
concept of majority because you have no
idea how many nodes are participating
and you only have a rough estimate of it
and you can't really achieve a majority
anywhere and so I'd actually be
interested looking at the the deep
access you're describing and see if it
actually somehow does away with concept
the majority or has at some form of rate
limiting admission control or something
so that on each round you know what a
majority is defined to be or something
like that yeah um he's got a sigmod
paper about it um let me let me share
that sounds cool I'm not gonna read it
in your house yeah sure um so okay so
Bitcoin under the hand is a public
blockchain any machine can join early at
any time and so this means that there's
this interesting class of attacks which
is since
we did rely on a majority of machines
for any concept of that an attacker
could just create an infinite number of
virtual machines and overwhelm anything
we come up with and so that that's why
we can't rely on a majority is because
of the existence of virtual machines we
don't have a good way of tying users to
a physical resource which they only have
a limited ability to get so what can you
do well we need to do something
different we need a new consensus
algorithm so let's invent it and so the
way I'm going to explain this is we're
gonna just gonna invent the consensus
algorithm from scratch one step at a
time
identify the problems and then add to it
and see what we can come up with so what
are requirements every time we add a
block to the blockchain it needs to
eventually be consistently replicated to
all of the other nodes in the system
I'll sorry I should say all the other
good nodes any node that's turned evil
we don't care about because evil nodes
can do anything um the newer blocks have
to point to this block so we have to
actually create a chain and not a bush
or a tree of blocks because that's not
useful to us nodes should be allowed to
join or leave at any time while
maintaining consensus amongst the nodes
that are still in the system and also
without causing a deadlock by having
this happen and to be clear we want
those be able to join or leave at any
time but we can't have something like
all the nodes leave at once because then
we don't have a system left or you know
an infinite number of nodes join right
now because well you know it has to be
within some realm of reason and I'm
being very hand wavy on the definition
that because there isn't a strict formal
definition I'm sorry and it has to be
network partition tolerant and so I'm
told you've talked about network
partitions if your network breaks you
now have to distribute systems where you
once had one and so each half of your
partition has to be able to keep on
working and should be able to form a
consensus and when the partition heals
so does the consensus so we might have
to consensus these that merge into a
single one and this is weird I just want
to really emphasize it this is weird
this is not what consensus means when
you're doing Paxos or pbft or two-phase
commit or one of the other protocols
consensus in those cases means you have
a commit point
actually I'll come the next light once
you have a commit point you'll achieve
consensus it's not going to change
you're done full-stop blockchain on the
other hand with this consensus is you
get to a point where you say at this
point we probably every and at this
later point we're probably more sure
that we agree we're never going to be a
hundred percent sure but it should be
good enough for you know your bank
account balance right and so if a
computing superpower happens to zoom in
and totally mess with your blockchain
well the whole system could be hosed and
it might change your bank account
balance but you know why would they so
yeah we're all good right and so we've
changed the definition of consensus to
being there's a firm point in the
algorithm where you know the answer for
sure to one where there's a firm point
algorithm where you know with very high
probability and you can make that our
probability almost arbitrarily high but
it's only with very high probability
that you've achieved consensus so
I hope you're good with that because
otherwise you're not going to be using
blockchain consensus so let's start
building our algorithm now that we know
what the requirements are let's assume
that we've got three computers in there
trying to achieve consensus and computer
one decides to add a block to the
blockchain cool so it's added a block
and then it tells its friends it tells
computer to and then it tells computer
three and we've replicated and we've
achieved consensus whoo our algorithms
working so far when you generate a block
you tell another computer about it and
they keep a copy or block simple
algorithm so far we add more blocks
while computer one adds another block it
gets replicated to the other computers
okay and we just keep on building it Oh
what happens when computer one and
computer three at the same time decide
that they want to add blocks to their
blockchain well they follow the
algorithm as I've defined it so far add
a block tell your friends so they tell
computer to which is oh now I've got two
blocks that come after the second block
and then they tell their friends and
they tell their friends and now oh we've
achieved consensus we have two block
chains this is called a fork and this is
not good news for your block chain when
when you have a fork because we wanted a
chain and not a tree or a bush so the
question then becomes we need to add
another sector algorithm which is if a
for happens how do we result it and like
all good distributed systems the best
way to resolve something is just flip a
coin pick randomly so let's do that each
computer if it wants to add another
block it picks randomly what block it
will build off of based on the longest
branch that it sees at that time so a
computer one picks randomly happens to
pick the one on the right adds another
block and replicates computer to which
then replicates computer three and now
our fork is resolved it's resolved
because now there is a single longest
chain in this block and so all future
blocks will be added to that longest
chain great
and we keep on adding blocks and we're
happy okay so our algorithm now has two
steps one is when you add a block you
just add a block to the block chain
until your friends the second is if
you're not sure where the parent of that
block is pick randomly amongst the
longest block chains that you observe
okay so that leads to a case where we
might have life lock this case computer
one picks randomly happens to pick the
know it on the Left adds a block
computer three at the same time picks
randomly happens to pick the one on the
right and now both computer one and
computer three are really clear they
both have a longest block chain that
they should add future blocks to and so
they do they just keep on adding blocks
and making compounding the mistake
computer twos gradually catches up as
the network messages reach it but you
know this can go on forever both
computer one and computer three can keep
on adding blocks they're totally
convinced they're right because the
algorithm says they're right and all the
other computers are just like I don't
know which blockchain is correct and we
never achieve consensus and just keep on
going going and that's no good and
eventually everything replicates and
eventually well no it doesn't because we
kept any more blocks so is this what the
blockchain community refers to as a fork
yes okay yeah this is this is this is
what the blockchain call community calls
a fork when when you happen to have
blocks that were added to two different
block chains at the same time and you
want your fork to result because if your
fork is unresolved then you've got
transactions let's say I paid Lindsey
money and I also paid Bob money but I
gave them the same dollar and that mean
that means you've invented money and
that's not good for a current currency
and so yeah you want your algorithm to
if a four Captains were to be resolved
as quickly as possible
so let's talk about that why do we have
this live lock and I'm going to ask ask
the classs what's the fundamental reason
why our algorithms we defined it so far
as live locking
you
and I don't know if questions will
answers will go through you Lindsay or
people can unmute an answer or yeah so
as the there are already some people
typing good
in chat sounds good so there's also a
slight delay on twitch so which makes it
more fun ask questions like this yes
well okay so one person suggests skin'
currency absolutely if we didn't have
concern see we wouldn't ever have live
lock but in spite of so what kind of
concurrence here what is the aspect of
this concurrency that's causing us to
have this trouble and and timing timing
yeah about the timing
well this is so much easier when you're
live right right so something about
scheduled non-determinism perhaps that
probably helps but the fundamental issue
that's going on here is that we can add
blocks on a node much faster than we can
learn about other nodes that I've had
opposed the time it takes for me to add
something to a data structures really
short but the time it takes for me to
learn about something that happened in
the other side of the planet it's really
long and therefore as long as we can
keep on adding stuff to what we think is
the longest chain faster than we can
learn about someone else who might have
created a longer chain we rose this
algorithm will never work and so the
solution to this is to just slow the
system down why don't we just add some
artificial delays into the system make
it so that we can't have blocks faster
then we can learn about other people's
blocks and so that's what we do in the
blockchain in blockchain consensus I
should say should use my terminology
correct um we just insert a random time
out make and make sure that that timeout
is long enough that were likely to have
learned about other people's block
additions before we go in add a block or
self so let's see how that works out so
going on and we start a timer on all our
computers and we pick a random time up
and eventually one of those timers
expires so on computer one the timer
happens to have expired first because it
got lucky and so it adds a block and
then what it does is a try sets start it
starts a timer again because it has to
wait some more and add a second block
and it communicates with all the other
computers it knows about about that
block and that communication arise
luckily before the time I would expired
on computer tube and so it starts a new
timer after add in that block and
similarly with computer 3 and we've
achieved consensus our fork has been
resolved because now all the computers
participating the system have learned
about the new block and they're you know
have a new timeout going so it perhaps
worth pointing out that that something
kind of related could happen with paxos
if you have multiple
proposers and the proposers messages to
the acceptors are interleaving in just a
way that makes it so you can never get a
majority of acceptors to accept so when
that happens one way to fight that is to
have different lengths of timeouts on
the different proposers so that they're
not always incorrectly intersecting with
each other and so this idea of random
timeout length before a proposer tries
again could help stop you from having
this situation of dueling proposers yeah
this is such a common concept that like
at least when I was at Google part of
the standard library that everyone used
is there is a random timeout function
you know you've got you Texas and you've
got random timeouts the the two tricks
to solving all your concurrency problems
right you put put in a bunch of me you
slow your program down and suddenly it's
mostly works I don't do that be very
careful but we're used both those tools
but sometimes people aren't so careful
and so I yeah if it works really well
right so then you ask yourself how do
you choose your timeout and this is
where the deep mathematics and science
and modeling of blockchain comes in uh
no actually sorry I take it back you uh
just yeah okay so you sort of guess um
what you really want is if your timeout
is too long your system will be too slow
if your timeout is too short your system
will be too slow
that's sort of counterintuitive the
reason they'll be too slow if your
timeout is too long it's because your
computers will be just sitting there
doing nothing for too long and doing
nothing is not fast if your timeout is
too short your system will be constantly
adding blocks constantly generating
Forks as the various nodes can't
communicate with each other fast enough
and it will take too long before one of
those works eventually maybe gets
resolved or you might get in a livelock
situation where it's never resolved and
that would be infinitely long so that's
kind of slow and so you have to have
your system try and guess where it is in
that spectrum and pick a reasonable
value and the conservative thing to do
is just pick out timeouts that are too
long and then you always know where you
are and you're happy so that's one
problem solved which is Forks we can
solve them with random timers so let's
see what other problems we have to
interact them let's talk about network
partitions so we have our three
computers they're working along building
the blockchain and a network partition
happens suddenly computer one in
computer two can talk to each other but
they can't talk to computer three and
computer three also can't talk to
computer one in computer - so what do
you do well you keep on running the
algorithm the computer one happens to
add a block because it's a timer expired
and it communicates it the computers
computer doing it never learns about on
computer three well Oh computer threes
timer expired because it's timer was
never reset because it never learned
about this block and it adds its own
blocks and so you just keep on adding
blocks but something to notice is that
there are more timers on the left side
of this diagram with computer one in
computer two then there are on the right
side so the probability of one of those
timers expiring faster is much higher on
the left side it's twice as high as on
the right side and so therefore it's
going to more than likely grow faster
than the right side because there happen
to be more computers on that side of the
partition and usually when you get a
network partition it isn't a nice even
split down the middle especially in a
global network it's usually like one
data center happens to have fallen off
the network or one country's network
cables was subject to back off a door
someone's shotgun shell in the middle of
the woods or something um that's
actually an entire another topic of what
causes network failures and longest
networks
it's amazing the stories you hear of of
well it's mostly backhoes but you also
hear about bullets and avalanches which
are kind of cool um I believe we discuss
tobacco's and tornadoes in this class so
far yeah I promise I don't know what
stories are public what ones they're not
one of the most epic stories I heard was
an avalanche in the Cascades that cut
off an entire data center for more than
a week I believe it was because did it
was just too dangerous to go in and fix
the cable because the snow was unstable
um so anyways um whoever's on the bigger
side of your partition will go faster
and because of that they will get more
blocks on there which means that when
the partition is resolved
our-our Guerlain just continues to work
the data is replicated and then computer
three suddenly realizes how I was wrong
the consensus I thought we had was wrong
and I'll just start working on the
longer side of the CH fork and we're all
happy again now even though while the
partition was happening you might have
gone and told your customers oh we've
achieved consensus and I've given your
money and then you're like oh I got a
clawback
you know so you probably in a reasonable
implementation of a Bitcoin client
before taking any actual real-world
results such as cashing out money you
might want to have a check to make sure
that you have good network connectivity
to a majority of the nodes in the world
because otherwise you could lose a lot
of money and that's actually issues like
this is one of the reasons why it's
often so easy to put money into a
cryptocurrency but hard to get it out
because the people who take the money
out are taking a real risk of something
went wrong which their code failed to
detect and therefore they're going to
lose real money when they try and give
you back your fake money
Syrena take virtual money so a couple of
questions in chat um so that here's one
that I this might be really specific to
Bitcoin but I I think it might go back
to the the discussion of Forks so the
question was about the splitting of
Bitcoin to Bitcoin
cash bitcoin SV and regular Bitcoin and
what happens there so I don't I don't
know the answer to this question at all
because I I don't know anything about
Bitcoin so is this is is this like a
Bitcoin specific question or is this
something that that you're qualified to
answer your Chris or what do you think I
would claim I am not entirely qualified
to answer that question because I'm not
an expert in cryptocurrencies but when
you do have a fork into multiple
algorithms or multiple cryptocurrencies
mm-hmm
basically you need to get all the
participants to agree that they're gonna
fork don't at least the ones that are
going to do the new currency and if you
don't well then it just doesn't happen
because you never get the majority and
you don't get consensus across all of
your notes okay
I wasn't sure if this was a question
about working or if this was some other
Bitcoin related question so so forking
has to like all great terms it has two
meanings in the cryptocurrency community
one is where you are forking a currency
you have the US dollar and you want to
fork it into the new and the old US
dollar and you can't trade between those
two new currencies and I believe that's
what this question is asking I see
okay the politics of taking a single was
a single currency and splitting it into
multiple currencies with different rules
of the game for the new multiple
currencies maybe different algorithms or
different trading rules or whatever when
I'm talking about forking this talk on
what I'm talking about is the very
specific short term two different nodes
happen to have come to different
consensuses and then later they needed
to merge their world view into a single
world view again so that they can only
have a single watching and so that's
what this example in the number
partition is day
okay did you have another question cued
up you said uh yeah so there's one here
I'm will see if I can summarize the
question so so after a timer expires so
that the the question is when a process
is timer expires does it randomly choose
a block I'm not sure if I I'm not sure
if I understand the question actually so
I'm not sure if I can rephrase it
properly so there are multiple questions
that might be buried in there one is
does when the timer expires has to
randomly choose where to add the block
what which what parent block to point it
to and the answer is if there's a single
longest chain as viewed by this node no
it's not random it picks the longest
chain if there's two or more chains
which have the same length
which it needs picked on and yes it does
randomly pick a parent node but the
other question you might ask is how do I
decide what transactions go into a block
and that's a very loaded question
depends on the cryptocurrency what a
miner chooses it might be for example I
you could say that when when you send a
transaction to a mining note saying I
want to be added into a block the
blockchain
you accompany in your transaction say
not only am I giving Lindsey five
dollars I'm also going to give whoever
happens that this is the blockchain a
tip 25 cents for doing the next work and
so they might sort all of their
requested transactions by the tips and
take the ones that make them the most
money mm-hmm first and so I there are
that's one mechanism that's used in
order to decide which transactions get
put into a block but that's not really
the topic of what I'm talking about
today because yeah that's not part of
the consensus that's part of the the
economics of the system and how
transactions occur any other questions
that's it for now
sweet I will move on
okay so yeah great so what's left we've
covered how to create a blockchain we've
covered how to deal with Forks we've
covered how to deal with network
partitions and choosing a timeout value
we've only roughly covered what you
basically do is you do it empirically
you basically say if the new blocks are
arriving too quickly and we're getting
too many live locks you slow down and
Bitcoin actually does this by every 14
days it looks at the average transaction
rate over the past 14 days and then it
adjusts its timeout such that one
transaction is expected to occur every
10 minutes which is to me that sounds
insane but it's what they choose to do
which is one block edit every 10 minutes
that's really safe because hopefully the
whole network can communicate any
changes between it sells in 10 minutes
successfully ok so that's what big
windows but then there's one other issue
which I've sort of ignored so far which
is what if computer cheese what if one
of your computers lies about its timer
expiring first that's really bad because
it means that one node could earn all
the tips as I mentioned a second ago by
adding all the transaction in the
blockchain and no one else will give it
a chance to add any blocks so how do we
make a timer that can't be cheated and
that is the key thing to this entire
public consensus and so how do you make
a cheap resistant timer well there's the
elegant and cool way which of course we
don't do which which is we use
cryptography a cage the way to do this
using crypto techniques is trusted
computing module most of the computers
producing blockchain happen to have
something like Intel SGX and their CPU a
little Enclave Enclave where you can do
your trusted computing and it's really
simple code to say inside the trusted
computer wait a random period of time
and then spit out a little token that
says you are now allowed to do whatever
the next action is
and there actually is a block team
that's been designed around that concept
it's the Intel sawtooth blockchain and
it works great as long as you trust the
trusted computing module to always do
the right thing and sadly there are two
holes in this one is you have to trust
Intel to not leak their private keys and
the route of trust for the trusted
computer module not to want to corrupt
your blockchain and whether or not you
trust Intel well I'd argue you probably
already do trust Intel because you're
running on their CPUs anyway so maybe
it's not that much of a stretch to trust
Intel but the other thing you're
trusting is you're trusting the future
you're trusting that future hackers
don't suddenly find a way of a new hack
for whatever the latest patched version
of the trusted computing module is and
historically that hasn't been a
fantastic bet because our darn
researchers are just too good at finding
new ways of hacking these trust
computing modules and so I no one has
made a large long-term bet on a
blockchain that's based on that simply
because it's not historically proven to
be a good bet now I would love it if we
made these modules so good that we could
trust them for something as critical as
this um but it just hasn't happened yet
em and so there's always hope for the
future
so the elegant way doesn't work let's go
to brute force aka physics and so the
what this is the way that Bitcoin
actually doesn't and it's this if you
want to create a block before anyone
else will accept your block as a valid
block being added as the blockchain you
have to solve a math problem and you
need to prove to other people that
you've solved that math problem and so
the way you do that is you solve the
math problem and then you include the
solution in the block headers of the
block you give to everyone else so they
can verify that you actually did solve
this math problem and that you did
something that takes a long time to do
presumably as long as the time out that
you were aiming for and also for this to
work verifying that you solve the math
problem that for me to verify that you
solve the math um should be really easy
and fast because otherwise you could
waste a bunch of my time which I'd
rather be
trying to solve my own math problems so
how is this done it's called proof of
work and the way it works is like this
remember our blockchain data structure
and how I said there was a cryptographic
hash on each block that contained the
hash of the prior block well when we
create a block those headers don't just
contain a cryptographic hash they
contain a number of things but the other
key thing they contain is a nonce and so
what's a nonce a nonce is just an
arbitrary number you get to pick what
your nonces and your goal when you pick
a nonce is to make it so that the hash
of the block that you've just generated
has leading zeros how many zeros do you
say well the number of zeros is the
parameter that the big point algorithm
chooses to make it so that you can't
possibly generate more than six blocks
per hour and for the whole global
network
so everyone independently using the same
algorithm looking at the rate of new
blocks coming and can determine how many
leading zeros you need in your knots for
other people to accept it sorry not in
your nuts in your hash for other people
to accept them and so then since
everyone knows that well right now I
need four zeros for other people to
actually accept the block when I ship it
to them so I need to come up with some
random number that means that the hash
the block that I just generated happens
to have four leading zeros how hard is
that well remember I said it's a
cryptographically secure hash and
because it's a cryptographically secure
hash there is no algorithm that can tell
me what nonce I should pick in order to
get four leading zeros the only way to
figure this out is to guess compute the
hash get it wrong guess again compute
the hash get it wrong and so the
algorithm proof-of-work is how quickly
can you guess random nonces recompute
hashes and see if you eventually get
lucky in the lottery and have the right
number of zeros at the beginning of your
hash so you just burn power waste
electricity and eventually you might be
able to add a block to the blockchain
okay so that's it
that is Bitcoin consensus we just
reinvented it from scratch by going
through and knocking down the domino
solving the problems that with our
previous algorithms one by one and so it
combines two things one is the
blockchain data structure and it
combines that with the proof of weight
work race to add blocks we're just using
proof of work as a randomized time
so this brings up an obvious question
which is should you use bitcoin
consensus for your system so let's try
putting some numbers on this throughput
Paxos raft pbft you should be able to
get easily in a in a decent solution
thousands of transactions per second
Bitcoin on the other hand and a decent
solution get three to seven transactions
per second if you look at the average
transaction size and the fact that only
one blocks that are every 10 minutes huh
okay let's look at another number that
did that didn't look too pretty um
latency taxes raft and pbft image if
you're unlucky global network latency is
less than a second so you can add a
transaction to system in a second
Bitcoin before you're actually mostly
sure that consensus has been achieved
and you want to return to your customer
a result of yes you've successfully
transacted it's about an hour because
most people claim that you want to wait
until at least five more blocks after
your block is added to the blockchain
before you're sure you're not on a fork
and even that is not a guarantee right
oh it's not a guarantee but it's
considered to be good enough maybe
probably good good enough to exchange
money on and so yeah it's a bit of a
latency difference okay well let's look
at a different metric because you know
this makes Bitcoin look bad so let's
let's ignore them okay so energy usage
Texas Roth pbft I did some
back-of-the-envelope compilation and
said well it takes about one point
formula watt hours to do a transaction
so you know that's kind of you know
you're wasting energy
oh my god Bitcoin what have you done
Bitcoin uses a huge amount of energy for
transaction by comparison so you say
okay fine
this is all a horrible mess but can we
fix this and it turns out yeah we can't
fix us here let me turn down the volume
my cell phone because ringing on it we
can just use bigger blocks right
amortize the cost over and put more
transactions per block and we fixed a
lot of the throughput issue or even
better than that instead of waiting ten
minutes for every block have a
every ten minutes we win the
proof-of-work race and that ditch gives
me the honor and the privilege to add
more blocks as many as I want for the
next 10 minutes until someone else wins
the race and that's actually what the
proposal called Bitcoin ng proposes is
that winning the proof-of-work race
doesn't give you the ability to add one
block it's you know ability to just keep
on adding blocks until someone else wins
um
and so that solves the throughput
problem it decreases the latency to your
block getting on the blockchain although
not necessarily the latency until your
block is trusted to be stable on the
blockchain um and so we can solve the
throughput problem pretty easily
assuming we can get those changes
through on the Bitcoin system we also
decrease the Energy's usage easily by
switching to a nother proposal which is
proof of stake where instead of having
to win the a time out race what you do
is in order to get the honor of adding a
block to the blockchain you prove that
using that you have the most money in
the blockchain right now and it doesn't
firmly go to the person with the most
money because that would mean just one
person would constantly adding blocks
it's amongst the the amount of money you
have determines the probability of
whether it's your turn or not to add a
block to the blockchain and it's
deterministic so that everyone knows
whose turn it is next based on how much
money everyone has on the blockchain
right now so that works right so why
doesn't Bitcoin do this and there are a
few reasons one is currencies rely on
trust and
quite frankly if you make something more
complicated to understand fewer people
will trust it and because fewer people
trust it
they don't necessarily agree to changing
what's currently working right now and
if you can't get everyone to agree at
exactly the same time to change Bitcoin
it doesn't change because people keep on
doing the old thing and in transacting
on the old system and part of this is I
would argue a political problem because
the people who really like Bitcoin and
really like cryptocurrencies are the
exact type of people who are not
inclined to put a lot of trust in the
good intentions of other people and so
in order to make a change in this system
you have to get them to all trust each
other enough to actually make a change
which is hard and it proven to be almost
impossible in those cases so it just
hasn't happened okay so theoretically
you can fix it in practice
it hasn't been successfully fixed on
existing popular block chains there of
course there are a zillion in one not so
popular block chains where they do
everything in all possible combinations
of stuff so I'm gonna argue that the
performance issues can technically be
fixed whether they can be politically
fixed is another discussion but you
still need other things if you want to
generate your own blockchain consensus
you need a cult leader because you need
someone inspiring enough to get a whole
bunch of people to join you because if
you don't have a lot of miners and a lot
of people working on your blockchain you
don't get the security guarantees of oh
yeah your data will never go away
because you have enough replicas well if
you don't have enough replicas you don't
have enough replicas you don't get the
security guarantees of knowing to
possibly ever corrupt your history
because everyone agrees on what history
is well if you don't have everyone
agreeing on the history because most
people aren't participating a large
group of people can join you and you
know you're hosed it's sort of like
actually I was watching a backup salute
of a show called The West Wing last
night and a politician proposed that you
know what you don't seriously good about
gun control and they're like what do you
mean he's like well if you wanted to get
rid of the end your NRA it's really easy
you get all the people who are against
sorry who are for gun control to join
the NRA
and suddenly you've got three million
new members of the NRA they only have
two million so you just vote everyone
out of office and you're done and it's
like well okay that's it approach if you
could actually get three million people
to all march in the same direction and
do something silly is that um but it's a
real possibility with computers because
it's easy for easy for one person to
control a large number of computers and
get them to do something evil um you
also need to make sure you've hired a
cryptographer or better yet a whole team
of cryptographers to make sure you
haven't messed up because if you have
any flaws at all in either your
algorithm or your implementation of it
your cryptocurrency might be dead in the
water um and you also well this is
actually what I think is the hardest
part of the whole thing you need some
way of paying your block miners if your
block miners if their interest in
preserving the integrity of your
blockchain isn't aligned with yours then
they are not going to do it if they're
not making money off of it they're not
gonna do it an expensive proof of work
algorithm which costs a lot of
electricity to run and so if you're
building an application that doesn't
include some form of payment
with money reputation points something
that gets people wanting to do the right
thing you don't have a good application
for crypt for blockchain consensus as
far as I can tell because this algorithm
really relies on the fact that in order
to get the desired outcome you need to
have aligned interests amongst the
participants and they have to be aligned
in a way which they want to stay aligned
because otherwise they have something to
lose and so I I want blockchain
consensus to win just because there's so
many cool applications that you can do
when you allow a public consensus
amongst computers but I've not really
seen it personally
compelling cases for applications that
weren't oh and then you trade some money
there has like there has to be some
financial aspect otherwise it's I
haven't seen anything that's compelling
that I think will really truly work well
sadly
so conclusion here is so should you use
it well if you don't have a strong need
for a public consensus it's a pain in
the neck so don't do it
just use paxos or pbft and create your
own private blockchain and be happy if
you decided you want to use the buzzword
blockchain and you get some benefits
from using that data structure great um
if you do need a public consensus you
maybe should do this you should strongly
consider doing something else I'll take
the fortnight example they have servers
and I have a company and they just you
trust that that company is going to
enforce the rules of the game correctly
because it's it's honestly an easier and
better solution for many applications
um but if you really think you need a
public consensus and you think you can
get enough participants and you have a
mechanism of paying them to behave
correctly so that the incentives are all
aligned then yeah sure you should you
should use a public consensus on your
watching so side note here I was
actually curious how realistic is it to
worry about a 51% attack because if
someone evil manages to collect more
than half of your mining nodes it can
then add whatever blocks it wants to it
and say just ignore whatever you add
because it's sort of like a network
partition right where you have a bigger
half of the partition and so to figure
out what is a viable 51% attack you need
to know how big is the mining network
right now like hey how many opponents do
you have in this fight and so this is
public information which is how many
hashes per second is going on on the
blockchain right now it's one hundred
and twenty two point one tera hashes per
second as of May seventh so okay so how
can we break this well back in the back
of the napkin calculations the peak hash
rate in right now on the Bitcoin
blockchain is 120 million tera hashes
per second consuming about 3.2 megawatts
which is a mind-blowing figure so you
can buy a block chaining mining computer
it's for example this one I pulled off
the web of an ant miner s19 pro does 110
tera hashes per second for only $2,600
perfectly reasonable right to buy a
computer disk can
meaningless hashes for a second um so
you need to buy about a million of these
in order to take over the blockchain by
getting up to 51 percent of the of the
mining capacity so it cost you about 2.6
billion dollars so this brought to mind
who's got two point six billion dollars
in computers right now who could take
over Bitcoin so I actually used to be
obsessed by this because when I worked
at Google I wanted I was wondering if I
was actually working in the biggest
computers in the world and for a long
time I was convinced I was using the
biggest computers in the world um but
you can roughly compute an upper limit
on how many computers a company has by
looking at a balance sheet because if
they own property they're legally
required to listed under prop reading
equipment net on their balance sheet and
so if you look at the balance sheets of
various large computer companies Google
currently has 77 billion dollars for the
stuff now that concludes things that
aren't computers it includes the
buildings they put the computers in
cooling systems networking equipment
land the buildings they put their
employees and if they happen to own them
and not lease them um they might loan
roads they might own undersea Network
women who knows they own lots of stuff
but you know that they don't have more
than 77 billion dollars worth of
computers because that's how much stuff
they own so Google's at 77 Facebook's at
37 apples at 36 Amazon well they
probably owns an inventory too so they
probably don't have that many computers
but they're doing pretty well um
Microsoft so the answer is any of these
companies could conceivably have enough
compute power to win a 51% attack on the
blockchain so if they happen to have a
rogue employee that decided they wanted
to completely toast the company's
business and take over all the computers
and they have the technical know-how to
do so and stuff they might have enough
compute power to win a 51% attack and
probably not because these are probably
general-purpose computers and not
specialized man mining hashing computers
but it's evil then you have to ask the
question is well how good are these
companies defenses against such a rogue
employee and they're probably good
enough to stop such a rogue why I would
hope they're good enough to stop such a
real employee so it's probably not gonna
happen but the fact that we're even
talking about it being conceivable
might give you some pause for reflection
so there was a question asked in chat a
little while ago which is relevant to
this which is do a six somehow solved
this super hard math problem quickly and
compromise the security of the
blockchain and why I inserted to that
was well anybody who's serious about
mining is going to have specialized
hardware or at least anyone who is very
serious about it but it only helps so
much which I think your example
illustrates here that it only helps so
much you need so many of these
specialized Asics to be able to to
actually mount this attack and your
competition already has a six mm-hmm
like the ant miner s19 pro that is a
machine that's stuffed full of Asics for
doing nothing about computing hashes and
so I was thinking like Google has I
forget the public names of their chips
in them but they've got any specialized
chips for doing AI and they've got a six
in them I don't happen to know how good
those chips would be if you repurpose
them for doing nothing but computing
hashes but they they also have computers
full of video card chips oh man these
processors also would be better at
computing hashes then as simple CPU so
yes the mining the mining computers will
win the race but there also are tricks
that can be played with general-purpose
computers a few people in chat are also
mentioning banks and governments that
they think would be able to conceivably
mount this attack yes I I don't know of
any banks with billions of dollars in
computer infrastructure they certainly
have impressive data centers um well I
haven't looked that closely and
governments I sort of put government's
in the bin of well we'll never know
because the people who do know aren't
allowed to tell us and I would argue
that ok from what I know of data centers
the NSA probably does and NSA CIA the
secret three-letter agencies of the US
government they probably do have some
very large data centers but I would be
surprised if they were quite at the
scale of like the commercial vendor like
Amazon or Google another point being
made is not only the the computers but
also the power consumption yes yeah no
it wouldn't be economical for these
companies to do it I'm assuming the
malevolent attacker who's more than
happy to waste Google's or Amazon sort
of Facebook's electricity if they could
you know destroy their entire business
by repurposing the computers for
something that makes no sense so we're
we're actually well out of time now
which I know that's a price but because
we got started 10 minutes late so we
should probably wrap up well luckily
this discussion is very interesting
here's the last slide all right
block chains are a great performance act
proof-of-work allows for publicity
public consensus at a huge performance
cost which you have to be willing to pay
in order use it and it's kind of cool to
learn about the stuff because it lets
you understand cryptocurrencies
um and I'd love for it to be useful in
other domains but they ain't there yet
in my opinion there are some very strong
opinions that people have who would
argue otherwise sorry I'm not one of
them and that's all I got also I'm gonna
put a blatant plug in for if you want to
see some more videos on other
distributed systems topics that are way
more simplified than what Lindsay's
teaching you you check out my website
all right well thank you so much Chris
I'm going to flip stream yard back to
showing your face instead of the slides
and then let's see here we go so thanks
again so classes let's say class is
officially over at this point because
we've already been here for so long but
just in case anybody still has questions
because this is a fascinating discussion
I'm wondering if any students in the
class have have more questions to ask so
an either about
either about blockchain consensus or
about anything else that chris has
worked on and so okay here's one
question that just came up which is it
could you possibly explain the concept
of proof of stake a little bit more
because it seems less straightforward
than proof of work I'd love to but I'm
not an expert in that area okay um I'm
one of the people who when I read about
it everything I read about it everyone
has a slightly different twist on the
algorithm and I'd have to go through and
read the code to really deeply
understand it I haven't done that
okay here's another question so the
question is suppose there's a fork and
node one chooses block a after it's
timer expires node t chooses Block B
after its timer expires is there any way
for this fork to be resolved like can
you can you merge the branches of a fork
or is it just forked forever
so yes the fork will get resolved when
the next block gets added assuming it
gets added to only one of the two
branches and then communicated
throughout the network and at that point
though the losing side the block that
was that was put on the shorter branch
will just get ignored by everyone and so
there is no merging of the transaction
data all the transactions that were in
the block that got on the abandoned like
of the work of Amanda branch of the fork
then have to be resubmitted to the
system and hopefully how minor will
successfully get it in a block that gets
published on the actual block okay merge
was the that wasn't actually the askers
term that was my term I guess I'm using
I'm still using a get metaphor to think
about this yeah so so yeah I guess it is
it is interesting because it has the
ability to merge which is which requires
human intervention mm-hm and so until
someone comes with an algorithmic way of
merging arbitrary content which of
course they never will you well you
could come up with one right but it
would suck right you could say well the
merge is the empty string right sorry it
wouldn't always correct
no like there are merging strategies
like the coda file system is an example
of a system where you needed merging and
I guess background its coda file system
is a distributed file system where I I
can take my laptop and I can access
files and I can unplug from the network
and keep on changing my files and then
later when I replug into the network it
resyncs with the server and successfully
if the system works uploads all my pals
to the server even if two users had
conflicting edits the same file and what
the coda file system does is it detects
the case
have emerged where it can't urge
successfully say to people edited the
same lines of code and then it just flex
it back to the user and says your hoes
now buddy how dare you you and Lindsay
edit the same source file at the same
time you shouldn't have done that yeah I
was actually just reading about this the
other day because I was for whatever
reason I had to I had to read about
systems that made you get permission and
orders to do it right and so coda was
something that was referenced mm-hmm um
okay one one final question so uh do you
see any any potential for government
regulation of Bitcoin like four or
blockchains like for example the student
is suggesting for example NIST defining
a common blockchain approach and
possibly even incentivized in a way that
you don't have to have a ridiculous
amount of hardware in order to
participate this might be a question
more for a political scientist yeah I
would argue I'm a technical person so I
I can us I can't be authoritative on
this but my my personal reaction is no
no it can't work and the reason it can't
work is because we already have ways of
government regulated exchanging value
between humans that work really well
that's called currency like that that's
what money is it's a government mediated
exchange of value where if something
goes wrong in a transaction you use a
government median resolution technique
called a lawsuit or a war in terms of
international relations and
and it works really well for most
applications and so the whole purpose
between behind blockchains I'm sorry
cryptocurrency is not necessarily
collections is is that we can exchange
value between people without involving a
higher authority mm-hm
and so if you bring the higher authority
into it you'll be like well why did I do
that what's what's the purpose right
right if the whole point was not to
participate in government controlled
currencies than to put the government in
charge again
seems counterproductive yeah it would
get you back to where you were in the
first place with a solution that is well
quite frankly better for most
applications all right we're far over
time now and so thanks to everybody who
stuck around and asked questions right
up until this end but I think let's
think let's thank Chris for giving a
great talk and oh well I mean we had a
great discussion and I interject it with
lots of questions so I'm not surprised
please check out distributed systems
course comm for Chris's online course
and and thanks again see you all on
Friday yeah thank you for having me
all right thanks Chris take care like